hi there steve kaufman here again in
palm springs
um today i want to talk about the 10
secrets to language learning success
i even have a series of emails on this
subject which you can subscribe to
and
get into more detail on this subject
uh remember if you enjoy my videos
please subscribe to my youtube channel
and click here for notifications and by
all means join me at link
uh i just wanted to mention too that uh
one thing i discovered in vancouver was
these uh aloo bukhara
persian or iranian dried plums or prunes
that are a little sour a bit like the
japanese umebushi and they are delicious
and they're very healthy and they're
popular from
i don't know georgia turkey through to
india and i bought them down here and i
really enjoyed them and just had a
couple before
uh making this video
so you know i can't rem quite honestly
first of all when people say there's ten
secrets to doing this or six secrets or
seven secrets or three secrets
these are ways to grab people's
attention so that it's very common on
the internet and if you google you're
gonna find
3 6 7 10 secrets doing this that or the
other and they are quite useful you know
they got 10 ways that you can use baking
powder or
six ways to
keep
moths out of your
closet there's all kinds of these and
and typically it's it's very useful you
can click through them one after another
and it gives you ideas so even though it
it may seem a little bit sort of uh
the term now is click bait
uh i find that they're quite useful
so i do encourage you to subscribe to my
email series of 10 secrets
there aren't just 10 secrets there
aren't just 10 hints on how to study
better there might be five there might
be 20.
but i hope that each of these would
stimulate some thinking and and maybe
each person finds their own 10 secrets
to language learning things that they
find help them become more effective
language learners but the absolute first
one is the famous three keys that i
often quote the
again i don't remember her name but she
was the director of the languages
department at san diego san diego state
university and and she said you know
language learning consists of three
things your attitude or the attitude of
the learner
the time spent with the language in
other words not
sitting in a classroom listening to
explanations in your own language about
the language but actually being with the
language listening reading speaking so
time with the language attitude time
with the language and then this ability
to notice what's happening in the
language some people
will hear the language and just not
notice how it's pronounced so they'll
continue pronouncing it the way they
think it should be pronounced maybe
based on
the writing system
in their own language or whatever so we
do have to be a little attentive to the
language so that's secret number one is
really you know buy into these three
keys to language learning
the second thing is you know you got to
take charge of your own language
learning you can't be dependent on a
teacher or expecting a school to teach
you you have to drive the program what
are you interested in
why are you doing it and then you know
find things that you find
worthwhile doing and then do them
the third thing is
words are the key to language learning
that's why at link we track how many
words you know how many words you've
looked up how many words you've read
because
again when i was correcting people's
english it wasn't fine points of grammar
that made their english less effective
it was how they used words they didn't
have enough words they didn't know which
words belonged with which other words
the whole thing about languages is
acquiring words and then getting used to
how they work
getting a sense of
you know
the patterns of the language and that's
all based on words words and phrases but
phrases are patterns which consist of
words
also when you go to speak
again you're speaking words you're
speaking meaning don't worry about how
close to native pronunciation you may
have of course you're paying attention
to how the natives speak you're trying
to imitate it some people get closer
some people aren't quite as close it
doesn't matter if you're using words
skillfully if you're using words if
you're developing that feel for how
words are used in the language
time i mentioned time
make the time find the time
and in that sense listening is such a
powerful activity because it's helping
your brain get used to the language and
it's also something that you can fit in
almost you know
at all times of the day while in the car
on public transit or washing the dishes
and so forth and so on
find ways to motivate yourself okay it
might be the kind of content you're
doing maybe you're motivated by doing
space repetition systems find things
that motivate you
another thing is don't worry too much
about how long it's going to take if
your focus is on
enjoying the process then the
how long it takes will take care of
itself you will move along more quickly
if you're focused on enjoying the
process rather than if you're focused on
how quickly you know can i learn the
language
another secret i think is to not be too
focused on how much you could say at the
beginning it's fun to speak it's fun to
get feedback it's fun to interact with
people in a new language it's fun to try
to put some words together in a language
that we're learning but ultimately what
matters is how well can you speak in six
months or 12 months and in that sense a
major focus on input acquiring words is
going to be more effective than
using the limited vocabulary you've
acquired over and over and over again
you have to expand beyond that limit
range limited range of vocabulary in
order to engage with
native speakers in meaningful
conversation
uh and and finally
you know learning a language is a
process of immersing yourself
in a new environment
the really as i've said before there i'm
not sure there is a chapter 1 chapter 10
yes
obviously if you have more repetition
it's going to be easier but at some
point you're at you're looking at this
lake or the swimming pool you just have
to get in and get wet start somewhere
start listening and reading start using
the little bit that you can immerse
yourself
and if you do those things i think
you'll be successful as a language
learner
in the meantime for more detail on the
10 secrets of language learning and
again i'm not sure i've covered all 10
but please subscribe to my 10 secrets
email course all right then thank you
for listening bye for now